so I'd like to kick off lightning talks
for today we have had an amazing event
I'm so glad all of you could stay until
the end I think you're going to be
rewarded for staying we have some
amazing lightning talks line up for you
I don't I don't only give you a peek at
them because I want you to feel the same
excitement that I felt when I saw those
names go down before now there have been
some complaints from attendees about the
quality of jokes during the sessions I
moderate Jeremy is has gladly offered to
help so in the downtime between talks
Jeremy will be providing a higher
standard of jokes I don't think he can
do it but we'll let them give a chance
now as you've seen we do things
differently every pie that event and we
try to iterate and improve this event as
much as possible one thing that we've
noticed is that it's difficult to get
people to sign up for lightning talks a
lot of you are very busy and you don't
have time to put slides together to
solve this problem we decided we'll make
the slides for you and you just have to
come up and give the talk so for the
first time ever I want to invite
somebody from the audience to give an
impromptu lightning talk having never
seen the slides before do I have any
volunteers any volunteers at all okay
Brian Granger let's give a round of
applause Brian thank you for being such
a sport all you have to do the slides
are on my computer just press page down
it should all be self-explanatory
is this like one of those roasts the
head yeah ah alright let's go for it
volunteers volunteers I guess I
volunteers so these slides were prepared
for me Bynum focus I think that I'm
guessing that that's actually a lie in
the sense that they were probably
prepared by James we'll see okay maybe
maybe he had some help page down ok I
have not seen these slides beforehand
that is quite true don't worry I'm a pro
and actually there was a little bit of
preparation that happened in advance and
James I'm willing to give a talk that
you've prepared if you're willing to put
on an outfit that we've prefer and we
appreciate your high style New York
wardrobe but but we were starting to
wonder if you're really a supporter of
PI data and so while I give the talk you
need to put on a PI data t-shirt I need
someone to help me with my jacket all
right all right don't worry I'm a pro my
name is insert name here I'm an
unfocused board member my name is Brian
Granger I am an um focus board member
and i also am one of the leaders of
ipython and jupiter and I'm also
involved in a number the other project
in this ecosystem this wasn't actually
spur of the moment I was a plant it's
called theatrics people
but seriously I haven't seen this
PowerPoint before am I allowed to see
I'm allowed to say things that are not
on the slides right or a lot of say
things are not a slide you can rip so
this is this type of thing has been done
at other pie datas and I it so there is
some precedents for this one thing i
want to emphasize is that a lot of the
core members of the different projects
ipython matplotlib mud pies I pie we
have all known each other for quite a
long time all the way back to the early
2000s and some people here even before
two thousand and one thing that I love
about num focus and PI data is the the
family aspect of it people here I have
been involved in their lives and they've
been involved in my lives for a long
time and it's a great family but one
important thing is that families do get
to laugh together and occasionally laugh
at each other these slides we're going
to be PowerPoint but I'm incapable of
giving a presentation outside of the
Jupiter notebook that is
uh not entirely true I guess I should I
guess I should just stay on script let's
move on so welcome to PI data this is
the 12th PI data and the 12th and Ford
fourth PI data in New York City copyedit
we're glad that you all could make it I
hope I just said y'all and I think I did
seriously dude follow the slides we sold
over 530 tickets to over 350 attendees
needless to say it was a very profitable
event we ran 73 sessions with over 80
two presenters we added some new
sessions to our lineup first poster
sessions next what's new in the various
core open source projects discussion
sessions and birds of a feather sessions
we've already had amazing feedback from
you and would love to get more so I had
a great time at PI data NYC this year
the talks were very engaging and the
other attendees were amazing first name
last name company and first name last
name I'm guessing that you're supposed
to tweak this or something like that
please join me in a round of applause
for all of our presenters
here we go this event would not have
been possible without our sponsors I'm
assuming it's going to go through yes
continuum analytics is the founding
sponsor let's give them a hand dotto or
dado is a diamond sponsor bank of
america is a host here and for the
physical space and also platinum sponsor
and then other platinum sponsors are
Microsoft trazer data and two sigma gold
sponsor in max point and silver sponsors
of de shaw mote taza and edge stream
video media and community sponsors of
parsley o'reilly sorry my eyes are bad
Python weekly galvanize ACM I heart New
York pi ladies and wi m LD s which is
women in machine learning and data
science I think please join me in
another round of applause for our
sponsors
we couldn't have done this without the
folks at gnam focus numb focus is insert
patter here I think I'm supposed to save
something about none focus so numb focus
is a 501c3 nonprofit that was founded to
be a support and and to advocate for
open science open data science and the
software tools that support open science
and data science and then also other
aspects of that including education
outreach diversity and the PI data
conferences all many of the open source
projects that you have heard about
during these three days are part of Numb
focus and what do I mean by that numb
focus is the legal and fiscal umbrella
for these open source projects so from a
legal perspective I python and Jupiter
are part of Nome focused from a legal
perspective a lot of the other projects
pandas I that's well I don't want to
press page down it might be danger so
might be something else but please visit
the num focus site many of the projects
here are part of or about to become part
of Nome focus I am currently one of the
board members of Nome focus and I'm
trying to think are there other num
focus board members here in the room yet
okay Travis who's one of the founding
board members is going to give a
lightning talk one thing that that's
really important is that while open
software is free to the users of the
software it is definitely not free to
develop and many of us work full-time or
with a lot of our time or with a lot of
our spare time on these projects and
it's really important to support the
different projects we are very fortunate
with ipython and Jupiter right now to
have very generous funding a large new
grant
from the sloan more and Helmsley
foundations a lot of the other open
source projects that are part of them
focus do not have funding and that
funding the lack of funding has a direct
impact on their ability to deliver
features to you and to fix bugs and so
if you want to make a difference in the
open source projects obviously you're
welcome and encouraged to visit github
and submit pull request file issues and
participate in the technical work of the
projects but we also encourage you to
visit them focus come talk to us about
fiscal sponsorship as well it makes a
huge difference an example of the type
of things that many of our core projects
would like to do but are often unable to
do is that typically all of us are
working distributed teams so I Python
Jupiter we have people in New York we
have people in California people in
Europe a lot of the projects are like
this and remote work works great for
many situations or for many parts of the
development there are some really hard
technical problems where you just have
to get together in a room with all the
core deaths for a week and work on
something and right now there's a lot of
core projects that simply do not have
the money to do that and that prevents
them from tackling the big things that
they want to work on so again please
please if you've not already talked to
us visit numb focuses website to become
a fiscal sponsor this doesn't have to be
something huge and massive even small
amounts helped a lot this is critically
important because because sorry I've
gotten off of Mike you a little bit here
it's critically important I think I've
covered some of this I think one thing
that has really struck me is the rate at
which all of these projects are moving
right now and also not from it just from
a technical perspective but also from an
organizational perspective
what's happening with gnome focus is
just amazing the other night when the
other core projects gave their updates I
was just stunned to see what everyone's
been doing even though i watch these
projects regularly and we can't do this
alone we really can't we support I think
our best guesstimate right now is that
there are on the order of around 3
million users of these tools and so if
you think about what type of company
would you need like if you're going to
start a start-up and you're going to
have to build a staff to develop
software and have support people for 3
million users it would be massive
compared to what what we run these open
source projects on I don't in any way
mean to guilt trip you I want you to
feel good about these tools and for that
good feeling in your heart to cause you
to participate with us and again this
doesn't have to be money it could be
like come and help us work on these hard
problems together I hope it did did a
good job improvising the last two slides
after all I am an unfocused board member
please join join me in thanking everyone
at nub focus
especially num focus executive director
Lee Asylum come up to the stage okay
she's the one who approved these slides
perhaps not in their final form except
for this one yeah it's a surprise leah
has worked tirelessly this year
promoting and growing them focus
supporting our many projects and running
amazing event like PI data and I can
vouch for this num focus as it stands
today would not exist without all of the
things that leah has done over the past
few years her work is absolutely
spectacular in quality and massive in
amount the amount she works on behalf of
num focus on and on behalf of all of you
to put on these conferences is truly
spectacular so please give her another
hand flowers enter stage left
and Leah I'm more than willing to help
you get back at janes afterwards and we
can figure something up the future is
when we'll be hosting more PI data
events look for announcements from PI
data in the US New York City DC Chicago
north carolina west coast and also
internationally london berlin amsterdam
madrid montreal if you're interested in
sponsoring or hosting any of these
events please get in touch with us at
numb focus i'm assuming that uh and this
is really a question for Lee and James
that all of those cities listed are for
2016 okay Jeff so just in 2016 there
will be a lot of PI data event please
watch the num focus and PI data websites
for more information about those join
the mailing list for more information if
you go to the num focus website you can
join the mailing list follow us on
twitter follow us on twitter follow us
on twitter follow us on twitter sounds
like the presentation is basically over
or over it's a question I can't tell if
this is the last slide I told you not my
slides the meta humor isn't helping this
so actually that I think this is the
last slide yea high concept I was told
actually I was told that it would be
quote high concept that there would be
no quote fart jokes thank you thank you
so much Brian next up we have Thomas
Caswell he will be talking to us about
cycler would you like to make some jokes
Jeremy and up after Tom Candida Haines
how these things working sorry oh let's
give Brian one more round of applause
you know this but uh Brian's prior
career was as a stand-up comic he failed
miserably but it turns out he's a pretty
good software developer I wasn't kidding
when I say don't know how to use these
max this is actually Mike's laptop uh-oh
the other day it just came up Oh so uh
uh while Mike is fighting with the death
with the well mike is fighting with a
knack of my name is Tom Caswell I'm one
of the Kohli developers of matplotlib
mike is the other one and I'm going to
tell you about cycler which is a project
that we spun off of matplotlib during
the last development cycle so as you may
know one of the things that previously
was built in is we had a default color
cycle so if you just called you know
plot plot plot it recycle through a set
of colors the artists have a lot more
properties would also be nice to to have
a default style cycle so as you cycle
through that you know as you called pop
up wat you get a cell than a dash than a
dotted and then and such and as your
think about how to do this we're like
okay because of a color cycle and
aniline stat line style cycle but now we
have to have some way to say oh how do
these two cycles interact with each
other do I
do I zip them do I take the product in
the process of working through how we do
that in general way for the very large
number of properties we have we came up
a cycling so this is it's a separate
project it's hosted on Mac under mat
clubs organization on github there's
docs I don't think internet connected
because you know here's fun and it's
currently Pope installable and it should
be available in Conda very very soon ah
mate okay so this is how about you and
if you upgrade to map out live 15 which
we released 10 days ago and should have
been a condo last night this is a new
dependency so you probably have this on
your computer so the interface is pretty
simple there's a basically one helper
function which site called cycler that
you give it a string name and then an
iterable and it constructs a cycle over
that interval ah so if you list this
when you enter it over it you get back a
you go back dictionaries which are the
key and then the value by itself a
single cycler you know I've just taken
something that was a list made it very
complex but you know we have nice print
thanks that's good where the power comes
in is that these the circular objects
are composable so if I have two of these
I can add them and what you can't see is
that now addition is basically zipping
them so you get the pairwise lock step
through those two um you can also
multiply them and then you get
essentially the outer product um and
then then these things have some nice
convenient methods on them for instance
you can if you want this the same thing
but backwards I you can slice them that
reverses it if you want every other come
on you can you you can subsidize them
all the things you expect work on all
right so then was the weather is useful
so uh I guess I've kind of spoiled the
punchline there but notice if you just
add them together you set them together
you see I get three lines
of different line widths and different
colors great um oh by the way this is
this is all using NB egg which is the
notebook back end which if you know you
can see that the coordinates changing
and is interactive in your notebook um
if you multiply them come on right now
we have we have nine lines which they
cycle first first color then line with
and if you notice the these line styles
are multiplication is not commutative if
you do in the opposite order they cycle
in the opposite order as you'd expect
and these are not limited to just simple
things when you know cyclic the
composition of cycle returns a cycler so
you can build up very complex style
cycles ah relative with a very terse
amount of code um and you know this is
not limited to cycles you can actually
put data in these things so if you want
to for instance run a data sweep over
some prime Oh some parameter space I put
the color map name and then x and y and
then you get this plot which is our for
new color maps various will be the
default in 2 point 0 which will be out
in the next couple months and that's it
so we hope this is useful to you outside
of map la live as well next up can you
today's after that will be hailey young
Candida is on finding your own data on
social networks oh no it's I was going
to say in second person reading things
off that James has wrote tonight Lykke
it's some sort of terrible hostage proof
of life situation
keep the marriage keep me keep forever
to me imagine one of James puns right
now Oh give a second give a second
ok
that's that how do you do that oh I can
oh can you switch to know where the
setting a time something's wrong Oh
there's one thing we have to do
that is the slides
actually while we're waiting I'll just
introduce myself my name is Candida
Haines I have lived in New York for
almost 15 years I live in north carolina
now and i'm excited to hear that num
focus is going to be there by data next
year so
I just happened
so earlier today I presented a poster
called my my little data in a big data
world and basically I am just starting
out a project on retrieving personal
data securing it exploring it and then
identifying the tools that aren't big
data tools but enable you to come up
with your own questions and run your own
analyses on your own data that is that
you've put online I'm sorry so instead
of going through that whole presentation
I'm just going to go through a few
places where you can pretty easily
download full arc well full archives of
your own data online the example that I
used during for the poster was Twitter
and basically they just have a page set
up in your settings where it says recent
email that will actually say something
like retrieve your personal data it will
be something that you'll understand when
you click that button you'll get that of
course and you'll receive your data I
actually got my data pretty quickly in
two minutes maybe one you'll have an
index file that looks a lot like the
Twitter feed online has a nice gooey and
a search box and just to show you how
that works I can see all of the times
that I've talked about gratitude it
keeps me going i also downloaded
facebook and again they to find this i
bet i actually found it was easier to do
an internet search on the for data or
our personal data archive and then the
name of the social network that you're
looking for because the pages are setup
so differently and the interface doesn't
always make it easy to find your data so
ah you get to see my
my facebook page and down here you see
the settings again you have your general
account settings and right here which is
very easy to miss you see download a
copy of your facebook data and here's
what you'll see and I'm just going to
click ads do you can actually see what
kind of information facebook this is
scaring me is collecting on me that oh
wow that they're using to serve me as
I'm just going to leave that page right
now I also decided to look at LinkedIn
and I don't know where this is on the
page I read it and there you can
actually request data that they haven't
described as being part of the archive
that you can get from them which and
what you already get from them i think
is pretty robust now this is linked I
myspace which some of you may remember
you main you may notice that their their
format is a little different it's more
sparse sparser and oh wait this isn't
I'm sorry this is LinkedIn again where
did it where did it go I seem to have
misplaced my myspace data but they had
suffered HTM they had suffered HTML
files one for each blog post and this is
probably saving me a little bit because
there were some embarrassing things but
I was putting on myspace long before we
were as sophisticated as we are now
about what we posts online um oh all
right so here's a little Russian
roulette
I have no idea what's gonna show up here
oh great all right this isn't too
embarrassing actually um yeah okay
anyway if you are interested in doing
this yourself I'd love to talk to you
and collaborate and find out what you're
working on google me that's how you
spell my name za and di da aty nes i
used bing and thank you coming up now
hailey young we'll talk about
algorithmic music position is Mike
Williams it's coming up so much
you know kid feels like the Trans Am
with the mother jacket whose voice I
don't even remember whose kids voice was
I took my meets world lets me more
Python alright so my name is holly I'm a
student at New York University and I'm
going to talk to you a little bit about
playing with music and Python and we're
generally playing with computers and
music so the field that I call
computational musicology is a pretty new
field and it basically deals with two
different areas using an algorithms to
analyze music and that could mean
analyze and musical form analyzing
harmony analyzing melody analyzing
rhythm or trying to create your own new
music a lot of times those go together
you analyze old music in order to create
your own music so the toolkit that I use
I did not create this toolkit it's
available from MIT it's called music 21
and it is a very useful tool kit
basically it makes it as simple as you'd
think conceptually to create a score you
create notes notes at pitches notes of
durations you insert the notes into a
part you insert the part into a score
and you have a score then you could
write it to MIDI which is a sort of
audio ish file or PDF um so you can have
a PDF of the score um and it also comes
with some core power musical data so you
can do some nice analysis so some
strategies for algorithmic composition
basically can be divided into two
there's the ones that are more
data-driven where you're taking previous
um previously made um and musical pieces
and trying to analyze what makes them
work and then we re doing that yourself
or there's expert systems where you're
saying I know the rules of music where
I'm making up the rules I mean sick with
just what could be more people do
nowadays is they make up the rules of
music and here's what I'm going to do
and then you create the on still
randomly generated but randomly
generated guided by explicit rules not
by what you see from previous pieces so
just a few examples Markov models are
probably the simplest data-driven method
basically what you do is you say I know
the probability of going from Abby to us
see what I'm in this key
use a 50 per set so i'm going to write
music where the probability of going
from abby to a see in this music is 50%
but you can do that in more smart ways
you can say i'm going to translate
transition between chords of the markov
model or i'm going to be transitioning
with rhythms as a Markov model and what
I've been doing which I will talk about
with expert systems uses Markov models
just for the chord progressions but then
uses other more um more in-depth rules
for the rest of it so with expert
systems you can basically divided into
three categories there's musical forms
which it has to do with what's the
structure of the music there's musical
transformations which all music is
transformation all music is repetition
all music is transposition I don't know
if those words mean anything to you but
basically the music would sound totally
chaotic it wasn't all connected somehow
I'd to connect that you use
transformations there's musical
preferences because some things will
sound good and some things won't and you
have to have rules that tell you what do
and what don't um I'm not going to talk
about this long but there's also um
machine learning and computational
musicology for music analysis I've done
work an automatic key detection
automatic harmony detection I haven't
done any work at automatic music
classification but um I could talk a
little bit about that because from what
I do know which isn't a lot um and I
don't think we have time for questions
are we doing on Walter okay so first
I'll do a demo okay this one here this
I'll turn it off soon
okay I think that's enough you get the
fight that was computer generated yes um
what I'm using right now is musescore
that's I didn't generate this
environment that's a open source
environment for notation software but
like I showed you earlier what's really
great about music 21 is it can write
things to music XML which is a format
that other programs can read so I took
what I wrote in musicxml and now I'm
rating it through these four which is
another open source program any
questions um a program that I wrote an
expert system program that it used like
all elements of Markov models but it was
basically an expert system
I've been a fantastic pi day at a time
have y'all yeah excellent one more round
of applause for our speakers and
sponsors hi i'm mike williams i work at
fast forward labs which is Hilary masons
and you start up here in New York City
we do fancy stuff involving recurrent
neural networks and things like that I'm
not going to talk about any of that I
mean it's all about something really
stupid that you shouldn't do which is
trying to infer peoples gender using
Python and in case we run out of time
sorry what I'm going to talk about is a
data skipped over slider sorry a data
set the Museum of Modern Art dumped on
github their data you can find if you
search for a museum on our github and
it's their collection of all the work in
the archive and I used that to look at
how things how their collection what
they were quiet is very very good time I
wrote a blog post that I put on a
website I felt like the world didn't
have enough introductory pandas
tutorials so you can read that if you
want know how to do group buys and
there's the slide that was out of order
that's the museum modern arts get up um
now all the slides are out of order I
guess I ran random doc choice on this so
this was the slide I found when I ran
basic pandas on this this is a histogram
of the artists in the museum of modern
art in the painting and sculpture
collection which is a euphemism for the
art you see out in the museum so not
ephemera not Prince not photographs and
what you'll notice this is the top 20 is
that's a lot dudes every single one of
those people is a guy so I decided to
play with an appalling lee named python
library called sex machine these talks
being recorded right sir um sex machine
is a bad library and I don't care who
knows it it's a it doesn't determine sex
it determines gender they're not the
same thing I need
doesn't use machine learning so that's
the way which is a bad name how does it
do what it does it is a pickle of a
dictionary that's how it does what it
does and the diction the keys of the
dictionary that they are tuples the
tuple the first value is their first
name the second value is a country then
the value is their gender or the sex
machine Charlie calls it their sex so
you might see for example John United
States and the value would be us sorry
male you might see Jamie United States
and that would be female you might see
Jamie United Kingdom or game thrones and
that would be male so it is a library
that in addition to being rather simple
is it incurs all the usual problems of
inferring peoples gender from merely
their first name namely that it's it's a
bad idea doesn't really work if you read
my blog I'll go into more details about
that but for the relevant for pi data
it's got a bad API here's the API no
that's that it's got an API only a Java
programmer could love so here this is
the entire feature set of this library
and every single line there is a line
that is obviously written by a Java
program so the first thing they do is
there is unnecessary hierarchy and
packaging system then we create an
object this is not an object and I'll
talk about why in a second and then
there's a gator function which you all
learn in intro algorithms and data
structures and now we don't use so why
isn't this an object did anyone see the
pike on 2012 12 talk stop writing
classes yes don't you know why this
isn't an object it's got two methods one
of which is in it if you write a class
with two methods one of which is in it
sorry i was saying object there i meant
class if you write class with two
methods one of which is in it you've
written a function and it should be a
mod if you if you've got data associated
with it then put it in a module if you
insist and so this isn't a class the
person who wrote this library could have
learned something for watching the pike
on talk stop writing classes and
additionally Roman hurting this
wonderful talk best practices for right
and beautiful code which starts off as a
pedantic bike-sharing rant about Pepe
turns into a great talk and I can't
recommend either of those talks highly
enough now which slide will come next so
this is the result this is what I found
so the data points they're having
inferred the gender of the 120,000 items
in the moma collection and thrown away
all the ones by or artists you've seen
before so this is unique artists and
then computed the ratio of artists that
sex machine is inferred to be female to
the rate ratio that set artists sex
machine has referred to be male you see
this result and then I used Seaborn both
to make my plots look a little bit nicer
but because it's got this really nice
lightweight linear regression model
which I turned into a projection by
changing the X limits of my plot and
you'll find that in just in time for
their 200th anniversary in the middle of
the 21st century moment will be
acquiring female artists at the same
rate they're acquiring male artists and
there's more details on my website thank
you up next Greg lamp with rhodium
should be easy for the computer to come
and it's already plug-in cuts even how
to hotswap perfect oh and Sarah
Schneider's up next with data
visualization sex all right I'm Greg I
am pooped okay work at Y hat we've
recently released a open source library
called rodeo it's 90 e for data science
installs with a dmg on Mac exe on
Windows we're still working out a few
kinks on links but give you a quick demo
it does a lot of the things oops a
little better so it does a lot of the
things that sort of an eclipse our
studio ipython style ide does allows you
to read in data from a script executes
it in a console has some features like
predictive type both in the editor and
from within the console as well
oops addition to that you can do some
pretty nifty things like taking a look
at some of your data sets little pop-up
in new windows you can explore them that
way as well and then lastly one of my
kind of favorite features and I
apologize that looks a little weird with
the aspect ratio but you can make plots
and just like the ipython notebook
they'll show up automatically and you
can play with them toggle between them
save them export them all that good
stuff if you want to download it just go
to our website why hot y hat calm /
products / rodeo thanks now we have
Sarah with data visualization aesthetics
I know I'm the victim of James
handwriting again very good I'm going to
a return Sarah's presentation please
stop making edward tufte fry
that way all right no honey gets going
she's going alrighty pretty much season
so I'm sarish Ned and I'm an artist and
a data visualization designer and I
recently joined continuum as a UX
designer on the bouquet team and I just
wanted to make the case for why to make
your visualizations beautiful really for
one reason I feel like and in my
experience both with art art and with
data visualization design if you use
aesthetics well you can create a
stronger intuitive relationship to the
data which can be useful I believe
although I I don't run machine learning
processes myself so I don't really know
this but I imagine it could make it more
it could help with the intuitive
relationship with your data set as you
go through machine learning process but
for sure for sure it's helpful for
explanatory visualizations that need to
be legible and compelling to people
outside of your your immediate team into
the general public so I'm going to show
you a few examples so this one here is a
version of census data with a dot for
every person plot it onto a map the data
shader which is a new project that
continuum is doing is a kind of an
updated version of this original project
but this is an example where the data
set just by itself is quite beautiful
when you plot it in its natural state it
is just color coded by race here so it's
pretty straightforward and naturally
quite beautiful um here's another
another example where a little bit of
aesthetic decision making making is make
decision making is happening this is
flight paths across the u.s. with like a
tonal value and kind of emphasizing the
path with some a different brightness
for the density around different cities
so you kind of get a sense of
the pattern in the data just from
looking at it this way another example
of this from stamen design studio in San
Francisco I thought might be nice to
show here this is a visualization that
shows the explosive dynamic nature of
the stock market by color-coding
different stock trades by size for the
size of the trade and for color for the
different entities doing the trading and
you can kind of see dynamics very easily
this way another way that you can use
aesthetics is to bring in metaphor this
is one you may have seen a visualization
of gun deaths in the united states where
there's a metaphor of the arc of a life
it's kind of giving you this strong
feeling of like the potential life of
someone who's who's been killed through
this unfortunate phenomenon and also
this color decision that's being made by
a life being gold and then once the
person has been killed after that is the
the rest of the arc of that what their
life would have been using using
national health data to kind of project
how what their lifespan would have been
so you can get this really strong sense
so don't just have this this numbing
number you actually have this experience
of what this data set means another
example if you can get some kind of
experience of the data that where the
visualization kind of mimics the
experience of the phenomenon that can
also help this this visualization
actually animates National Weather
Service weather data all over the
country when you see the animation you
can actually see the surface of the
whole country being shaped by the
movement of air over the country you can
also visually absorb enormous amount of
data this way if you were to look at the
actual tables that are running this
animation you couldn't possibly really
taken all of that information one minute
cool a couple kind of left field
examples you can also visualize
spatially that can really help this is
also
whether data this is a visualization of
National Weather Service data of a storm
formation 3d printed in aluminium as an
actual physical form sometimes one
aesthetic strategy artists do this a lot
is to use a different material than you
might imagine to give you this kind of
cognitive cognitive connection /
dissonant dissonance between your idea
of the data and the actual phenomenon to
get you to experience it kind of in this
visceral way and finally here's one
plotting Wi-Fi strength all over the
city of Oslo Norway this time-lapse
photography of a stick with LEDs on it
that sense the strength of Wi-Fi signal
as a landscape moving across the city
and this architectural group walked over
the city to create this series of
visualizations as a wonderful film on
video on vimeo about the project to
conceal it than other people there and
now i'm finish thank you
no jeez sorry call jeans up or where
it's only wearing the shirt
so I'm not going to talk about product
review vetrix I'm going to talk about
product review mining there will be some
overlap if anyone attended the session
on understanding product attributes to
reviews but i just want to show you my
approach and also a UI that I built it
shows a potential use case so um my name
is Anila i am a data scientist at a
marketing startup called contently we
help our enterprise clients tell great
stories so I'm going to start with a
story about myself I just moved back
here from Australia I know when you
think of us Julia you probably think of
like Steve Irwin and bondi beach but I
lived in Melbourne which is freezing
cold and had weather like yesterday like
with the entire winter so in Melbourne
um here's a picture of my house it had
14-foot ceilings it was 150 years old
but I didn't want to turn on our furnace
because it had the 14-foot ceilings
wanted to save some energy so i decided
i went to buy a space heater and because
i'm a lazy American i went to amazon to
look at space heaters um in all show
they don't even have amazon cause
they're living in the dark ages but here
is the amazon results in space heaters
yeah so I'm just like they're way too
many space heaters or completely
different technologies they all have
different effects I don't know which one
to buy I don't know which one for my
needs so it's like maybe I want
something that saves energy or maybe I
want something that heats the room
really well so I also studied economics
and undergrad so economics is a lot of
like TD line charts supply and demand
blah blah blah so I thought how would an
economist go about this multi objective
search now I might be like consider
trade off so you want a low price and
good for your energy bill try to plot
those two things and I looks a good
outlier so here's an example this is on
medium this is actually temperature
versus electric bill so you're looking
what I wanted was to have a scatter plot
like this that so I could look for the
good outliers so too
do this is basically two different tasks
one is to discover what are those axes
now I made price of default but the
otherwise you have to discover and
basically extract the product attributes
and I got these from reviews scraped
from amazon ho this is across the entire
product category space not just one
product and then I also and then you
have to do some sentiment scoring on to
score each data point along those
metrics which I may or may not get to so
I worked on this problem so basically i
created this apps that where you could
search for space heater and it would
return these automatically extracted
features so if you saw the other
presentation she did some topic modeling
she looked at some work to back i do any
of those things oh all i really had to
do is look for frequently mentioned
nouns for the you know grams i look for
frequently mentioned nails that were
mentioned at a higher frequency than
like a generic corpus because this is
like people are talking in a slightly
different manner because they're only
talking about space heaters and then for
the diagrams and trigrams i just looked
at noun phrases with a high PMI so then
you can go to explore trade-offs i don't
know if you can see this that well but
you can choose one or more features look
for the trade-off so for instance
electric bill and temperature we're
going to see this and then you can i
also mind correlation so to find those
trade-offs now some of these
correlations i'm gonna admit don't make
any sense but um this is really just
about exploring the space so electric
bill and temperature for instance so
these were all generated in d3 and then
you can look for the good outliers and
it will also show you how it scores
along other dimensions and it will give
you the contextual reviews because the
aggregates are great for the
visualization but then i see this i'm
also like okay where's the context i
want to see what the person said so yeah
there's an example of what you can do
with text mining it was NLT k mainly so
pandas and scikit-learn for sentiment
analysis thank you thank you thank you
an l a-- as a proud Melburnian i do have
to correct the horrific slur that you
started that talk with I'm sorry
Melbourne is beautiful it does not get
cold there nobody needs space heaters it
is always beautiful 5 to 30 degrees
across the year and everyone who thinks
that cold lives in this country because
all the Canadians are the moved on heart
sounds so good we're going to hear is
real time which is hold a five-minute
apology to continuum analytics yes as
it's some something I was taught growing
up is that when you make a mistake the
best thing you can do is come out and be
very public about it be very clear and
make a formal apology so this is what
I'm here to do today as a seep I think
or developer we make mistakes and and
this one in particular is one that I
know that continuum analytics is quite
upset about and so I do need to directly
address the apology to continual metal
ethics if you aren't familiar with what
they do one of their big products is
anaconda you go off and you download and
you get all of these packages pre-built
and and this is a really big deal on
windows because if you've ever try to
build a python package with C code on
Windows you failed I guarantee you fail
I fail every time I try to do it I fail
it's really really hard why is it so
hard the reason it's so hard is because
of the compiler we've used and the sea
runtime this is a little bit technical
but hopefully I can get by with no
slides oh I get the Anaconda logo behind
me excellent the reason is because back
when Python 27 in particular was built
the latest compiler was was part of
Visual Studio 2008 which shipped with a
version of the microsoft c runtime
version 9 point out
and that is part of the public interface
that link that compiler is very tightly
linked to the dll that dll is part of
the public interface if you build an
extension you need to use that DLL or
you're going to be broken when Visual
Studio 2010 came along we changed the
compiler and change the dll so to build
a package compatible with Python 2.7 you
need to use the exact same compiler that
was used to build Python 2.7 we can't
change the compiler or all the
extensions the world break and you can't
get the compiler because Microsoft
doesn't give it away anymore which is
not strictly true because I went nan and
sat in people's offices until they
agreed with me and weary released that
compiler so things got a little bit
easier that's not the apology because
Python 33 came out and 34 and at that
point Visual Studio 2010 was the latest
compiler so we used that and that uses a
different version of the sear on time
but it has that same tight linking if
you want to build an extension for 33
and 34 you need to use a different
compiler you need to find a different
compiler and it's not freely available
anymore you can still get it if you're
very patient or you work at Microsoft
those are those are the two conditions
what did I actually do that upset
continuum a huge part of their business
is building these packages that are
really hard to build and giving them
away so how could I spoil that for them
Python 3.5 on Windows is built again
with the latest version of the compile
of Visual Studio 2015 what's changed now
is the C runtime that comes with that
doesn't have a version number which
means that as the compiler moves forward
the interface for the sea runtime does
not change and so you can still use that
in 10 years time with a newer compiler
and the extensions you build will be
compatible all the way back to python
3.5 and also be compatible with 3.93
point 12 whatever up to at that point
and in fact if you use the limited ABI
marker when building your extension
there's a good chance you build it once
for all of those versions of Python and
nothing changes what I've done
by doing that change which was largely
my own effort going through the Python
code base changing build settings fixing
bugs is made it so it's easy for anyone
to build extension packages for Python
Continuum's big business model they pre
build the packages for you and give them
to you when I met Travis when I came
here he did not have his usual smile eat
just the beard the handshake was not the
usual handshake the greeting was
something that I'm not going to repeat
while I'm being recorded but it was his
normal politeness there would no there
was no swearing there was no angry words
there was you cost us a lot of time and
effort you realize I hope that they will
forgive me at some point I hope that I
can continue to be friends with my
friends at continuum but I also hope
that everybody takes the opportunity to
get hold of Python 35 if you're on
Windows and be able to build extensions
using a modern c compiler one that's not
going to break the next time we release
an update and build extensions that are
more reliable and more compatible with
all the versions of Python into the
future thank you